i am very happy to have tonight's guest
in studio with me
he's of course a very funny comedian and
long time advocate for racial justice
please welcome
the host of cnn's emmy award-winning
series
united shades of america w kamau bell
thank you for being here in person
uh yeah i came out for you i have not
left my house very much except to make
the show but i came out for you
that i i really do appreciate that
you're very kind
you shave shaved yeah i did it's like a
date i did the whole thing
i showered i washed my hair you put on
your best uh
purple oakland i put on my best oakland
shirt yeah
i mean man you all went all out and i
appreciate it no you were very nice to
come on my program uh during the height
of covid and
all kinds of craziness you came on and
we had a great conversation which i
really appreciated
uh and that was uh of course on zoom
and then i got to talk to you on the
podcast but again not in person
so this is nice we're here we're here
we're here yeah no last time we when we
first
did that uh thing on the show and zoom
let's see
there's a global pandemic uh racial
unrest and now
everything's okay
man the old days never another racial
problem in this country
all solved all solved you're welcome
america our conversation did it yeah now
first of all i want to ask you about
your
your health i'm told you had eye surgery
recently yeah i like to do all the
things i like to have a global pandemic
and also mix in some eye surgery so yes
i had eye surgery
uh i have i've had bad eyes but i think
for the first time i have this thing
called good insurance
oh so yeah it's a guy look into it
everybody should have been waiting until
you had good insurance to get eye
surgery yeah so even the global pandemic
cannot stop me from taking care of that
of my eye surgery so yeah
did it all go fine did it go did it go
well i mean right now i'm like an nba
player you see on the sidelines with
like the ice
like i'm gonna play the game but i'm a
little banged up so you can't even see
me right now no i ca but your voice is
so specific
that's clearly you it's clearly you it's
it's clearly it's me or some i'm a
blurry white lady to you right now
there's a lot of white men here but i'm
like no that's conan right there yeah
i know i tend to stick out yeah yeah
your your woke whiteness is coming along
nicely we're all very proud of you in
the bay
i'm trying yeah you are which we
appreciate you know
i am known as the whitest man in america
uh so i i felt like this responsibility
yeah that's why me and my friend kate
shot to
she pulled you along we're like if we
can get him we can get everybody yeah
yeah and then you realize no most white
people don't like me
he didn't really do that you should have
looked into that first i didn't know the
show was going away
i thought he's gonna be on tv you wasted
yeah you reformed the wrong guy it was a
huge
you know i have to ask you about
something which is i you do a terrific
show
uh you do a fantastic show and then i
find out that you're
up against steve harvey for
two naacp image awards and i was
thinking to myself
you guys are doing such different things
really
yes you really are unless you're
starting to give away a lot of cash
on united shades i don't think so i mean
you're out there
uh and you're you're doing these uh very
uh
you know probing and thoughtful uh
you know looks at what's going on in
america and racism and then of course
uh steve harvey god bless him has family
feuds yeah which is
i mean believe me that's i wish i had
that job yeah that's the job you really
want
that is the j i'm aiming for that job i
probably should have gone through
meeting with the clan to get there but
that's
i think it was funny that the guy who's
famous for meeting with the clan and the
guy who's famous for the big suits and
celebrity family flute
we're in the same category what have you
ever thought of if you really do like
that you could borrow a little from him
you know like you did that famous
episode where yeah
you went and you hung out with the clan
so maybe you do like a
game show yeah where you're with the
clan
you're trying to integrate them a little
and maybe that will change that well the
show is
basically america's greatest racism
every week we talk about the greatest
moments in america's racism but we don't
give away money we should start giving
away money
you know what you give away cars cash
prizes yeah
it's a whole other thing that's yeah
right before when i was nominated for
those two categories
uh i sent out a tweet that said i'm up
against steve harvey i look forward to
losing to him
and then i did lose to him yeah so yeah
i predicted it well i think the other
thing too
is you know that the quickest way to get
people
uh woke and maybe to get people uh aware
or racially sensitive is to say
hey at the other end of this if you
listen to me for 10 minutes there's a
possibility
you win a prius yes we should do that
that's how we should do that with a
vaccine if you get this vaccine you will
also get a prius
you know uh i can't believe because your
show
involves a lot of travel you're
traveling constantly through your show
and there's no way around that and then
you did it during covid
and i don't know first of all you
survived it congratulations
what was it like at the height of kovid
to be
flying uh you know to to to cover your
assignments well
and let's be clear as a you know as a
black guy who's
in my 40s who has asthma and maybe some
high blood pressure covert was looking
for me
like you know i would leave places maybe
like covered was just here yeah uh yes i
got
many times coveted called me i know you
hang with kamau and i'm like i
i can't tell you where he is he is on
the top of our list right
no yeah i was out there i felt like i
was dodging covert like neo in the
matrix
uh but uh yeah so we went out there
massed up shot everything outside you
know and like everybody was tested i got
tested every day and
you know there's and it's like rapid
tests there's like a half hour be like
is today the day
so yeah yeah so and what about airport
like describe i have not
been uh last week uh i had
to go up north to seattle quickly uh
uh there's something going on with my
wife's family and so i had to rush up
there and it was
i realized was the first time i'd been
on this airplane in such a long time and
in an airport and things
felt like they're easing back to normal
yeah but you were in airports what were
they like at the height of the pentagon
i was out there it was like i am legend
like i was the one guy in the airport
with a dog yeah i took a dog yeah like
there was and you're like
the whole time you're like is this
really a good idea yeah all the stores
are sort of open but nobody's in them
just like take what you want leave some
money
it's fine right restaurants make what
you need we're not going to be here yet
i was out there
getting on airplanes sitting in your
seat and you know
air travel is not the best anyway but
air travel during the pandemic they're
just sort of like this
they're just sort of tossing a bottle of
water towards you there's no yeah all
the luxury was gone yeah
yeah yeah but you got through it yeah i
did get i think you got through it and
you were able to do the work
yeah we did do the work we made seven
episodes of for this for this season
they cut one but we did we did we did
what we could do
and uh what about i know that you're a
hugger
no you know i am formally i'm glad
that's what i'm gonna say
former formerly a hugger yeah i have a
very tight hug circle now it's it's very
exclusive uh
i noticed you didn't hug me when i saw
you i said i have a very tight hug
circle now it's very exclusive
it's very plus i don't want to with my
eye i don't want to hug the wrong white
guy
andy oh no andy did you get a hug from
kamau when you saw that
yeah no it's a very yeah you know what i
respect that you're discerning you know
i used to be like every everybody can
get a hug you know but now i
i am not doing that it's all it's all
the uh the elbow i do the elbow thing
now yeah yeah and for years i used to do
this on tv and i found what do you do
andy i do this now sometimes to people
yeah and it's just my way of saying i
respect you
i acknowledge you you yes um i'm a
buddhist
i don't want i do the i do the run away
you just run away when i encounter
people i just run the other way
yeah you did that before before kovid
i'm i'm scared i was raised by wolves
[Laughter]
now you got your vaccine oh yeah i got
the j j i got that j and j that one shot
i love that everybody talks about which
one they got yeah did you ever think
would be talking about this because i'll
be some place and someone will say yeah
i got madara and i'll say like
i got modern enough yeah no and then
suddenly it's like you're an aries i'm
an aries
exactly who cares which one you got yeah
no no but let's be i
if you get the jnj you're really keeping
it real all you people need two shots
we're the ones who are really keeping it
real
i got one shot and i went home did you
have any side effects from it oh yes i
had all the side effects yeah
i definitely got real medicine some
people were saying it was fake no i got
real medicine
yeah well i you know it this is so
important because
i've been uh open about the fact that
i'm now
two weeks out uh officially from my
second shot i got moderna
and yeah i got some side effects you
know i got some side effects from it but
my point was yeah you're supposed to
yeah
and they're not that bad and you get
through them and that's like a message
you want to get out there which is
actually probably a sign that the
vaccine is doing what it's supposed to
do
it is and i think you know right now if
you read the news there's lots of like
other variants happening and so we all
need to get vaccinated
or else we're just leaving ourselves
open to another you know
version of covid that will come across
the way so we have to we're going to get
vaccinated now it's
especially important there is a
well-earned suspicion of vaccines
in the black community well there's a
well-earned suspicion of a couple areas
as well earned suspicion of
the united states government there's a
well-earned suspicion of
the medical industry there's a
let's just say everything let's just say
of america can we
put it all under america right so i
understand that like
that uh and you know black people that
we are a little bit skeptical which is
why it was important for me i did a
thing with a bunch of black doctors and
healthcare workers for black doctors and
healthcare workers talking to black
people about the vaccine
in ways that black people understand if
i played it for you you wouldn't
understand it but uh
yeah i didn't know and you just the
whole thing you just said nothing to me
yeah and i just heard a lot of like a
high just a high pitched squeeze
[Music]
now that i understand that i understand
yes yes but uh
but i do think and it's it's other
communities as well i
i know people i work with people whose
um parents immigrated to this country
from other places who are suspicious of
the vaccine
and they they just it's culturally
i mean we're up against a lot of
cultural stuff as well and we're also up
against a lot i don't know if you
remember the last four years of america
we're up against a lot of misinformation
and lies so
you know i mean if you look at the
research you know if you want to get a
vaccine you can't get one in your
community
go to trump country because they don't
trust the vaccine either
so i think that we have to understand
that like there's a lot we have we are
awash in misinformation and lies right
now so a lot of people
don't trust the vaccine because they're
taking in the wrong information well
what's fascinating to me is anybody
who's had a brush with the disease
actually had covid or known someone had
covet
they they get religion really quickly
yeah yeah which is which we shouldn't
have to do that no it's too bad yeah
you know there's it's in the news that
yankees
the mets are offering free tickets to
anybody who gets
uh a coveted vaccine and this a little
bit goes back to
we were talking about with the family
feud is you know if we want to solve
america's problems maybe we should offer
people
you know uh a new car right um
incentives feel like they might be a
good idea in this situation it's weird
to say
want to save your life we'll give you
something for free yeah but that feels
like where we are right now
well yeah and i think well there's a lot
of us who are like i would just like to
save my life tell me what to do
you know i will wear a seat belt but for
other people you have to incentivize
especially with kovid because it's not
just about your life it's about the
lives of the people around you in the
community and the country in the world
so you have to incentivize it i think
they should just like wasn't it krispy
kreme giving out donuts
yeah i think they should just sneak up
behind people jab a vaccine into them
and they go hey donut
because you'd immediately forget that's
right how how dare you
just like yes donut doughnut that's i
think we should just look at it that way
like we have to because we have to get
vaccinated or else we're
how do i put this we're doomed yeah well
what a lovely
yeah you know what a lovely sentiment
this is that this is why i'm the
comedian who works at cnn
i gotta say i saw you live many times
you would always end on we're doomed
yeah yeah that was it always bummed the
crowd out
i was trying to make it a catchphrase
but that didn't seem to work
we're doomed he's about to be off he's
gonna do we're doomed right now
here we go that's my closer um i talked
to you
uh at as we mentioned before
months ago right after
george floyd's death and
um well let's be clear we can say murder
now murder yeah
but i talked to you right at the height
of that and so
it feels like i i'm curious to follow up
now that the trial is over and uh derek
shelvin's been found
guilty three times of all of the charges
where are you what's your reaction to
that verdict
and the reaction to that verdict i mean
i think uh
so first of all i'm happy for george
floyd's family that they got a measure
of justice
in the civic trial in the criminal trial
so good for them for feeling like they
were heard but
you know if any police in the country
should have been aware
of how they interact with black men
specifically it should be police in that
area
but dante wright was killed right then
right after george floyd right after
shelf was found guilty so i think a lot
of people
have been in the position uh because of
the work i do because the first episode
of united states which is about policing
of people asking me to be hopeful or
wanting me to say we can be hopeful
because of that verdict
but you know i'm old enough to remember
rodney king you know like we thought
like oh they got it on film that's going
to change everything
i'm only remember that weird thing we
thought oj being found not guilty was
good you know that weird period of
america so i think that until we
recognize that it's the system of
policing that we have to look at and not
individual acts that we're still going
to see these things repeat themselves um
you know it's interesting because
there's this the movement defund the
police which
is first of all good for you for saying
it out loud a lot of people are afraid
to say it out loud
to say defund the police yeah yeah you
know my
issue with defund the police is when you
look into it you see that there's an
incredible amount of
nuanced terrific ideas to how we can
approach and rethink policing defund the
police
is can lead people in the wrong
direction
which is people think what do you mean
so no police which is
not the concept um uh and and i think
that's something
it's almost educating people what that
means and maybe there needs to be
another name for it other than defund
the place or i don't know
i mean i think i think of this in the in
the in the big picture way
you have to realize that like from the
first moment
that africans set foot on this country
and got off those boats and we're told
wait what do you want us to do
wait for for free right no i'd like to
go back
and then you would realize there was no
going back black people have had to
negotiate for our
for our rights and freedoms and
privileges right and we've had to do it
all sorts of ways whether it's like
what if i sing some negro spirituals
what if i what if i stand up as big
treat the power so black people as a
whole are always
trying to figure out ways to get the
attention of the greater white power
structure
to say can we have our rights and
freedom so i understand that people are
annoyed with the fun the police are
afraid of it but
let's remember martin luther king jr was
talking about hugs basically
he was talking about like can we all
just get along and he was assassinated
so i think black people are often in
position of like
how do we get your attention now
famously ice cube said
the police so i feel like the fund is a
little bit less harsh than that
right and it's true i think people get
put off by it so then it becomes my job
as the guy with the tv show to say let's
go through it and talk about it
because you're not going to google it
yourself so let me do it let me google
it for you you have a
uh a chart yeah maybe you could walk us
through the charts wow this is i've
i've never had physical high blood
pressure but i forgot this this is by
the way this is your eye test also
exactly so uh i love that i just told i
just learned you had eye surgery
and uh you yeah
you don't you just see a white blob with
some orange stuff at the top
i could be trump for all you know i mean
that's so small they defunded the
graphics budget didn't they yes we did
this is where we are right now we're
like we'll make a chart i was like great
oh okay
this is called defund the show exactly
what i hear uh
but yeah so basically if you look in the
middle of the chart you're saying that's
the police as we currently know them
and the police in many towns get like
anywhere from like 20 percent to like 50
of the city's money right now in oakland
ride from they get around 50
but only four to five percent of the
police are for violent crimes
right right and then everything else
becomes about like things that the
police
is under their umbrella to do but
they're not actually that good at like
for example
there's a guy in the street who's
yelling and seems like having a mental
health
episode can you come help that can you
come help with that
generally and we've seen that happen
over and over again the police come
that person often ends up dead and what
what the fun please is saying there
should be another number to call or when
you call
you should be and you say there's a guy
in the middle of the street who's having
a mental health episode then they link
you to a social worker
or somebody else who shows up to help
that guy like for example
richard brooks in atlanta was asleep in
his car somebody called 9-1-1
the police showed up he ended up dead
that should be 9-1-1 can you send an
uber to come pick this guy up and take
him home
and so what the fun the police are
saying there are better ways to handle
public safety than always calling
someone this is also something that
uh the police would probably be
interested in which is
they don't want to be sent into these
situations uh
and and it's using the wrong tool
for the wrong task there needs to be a
more nuanced full tool chest where you
can say
okay this is someone who has experience
who's not is immediately threatening to
someone who's having an episode and
knows how
and is actually their whole job is about
de-escalation and connecting with people
not squelching a threat not looking to
everything as a threat i think we think
of police
being like those old batman cartoons
where batman's utility belt had
everything on it right well really
police don't have that much on that
utility belt they have guns they have
they have taser maybe they have a stick
i don't know but they don't it's all
about how to squelch a threat and not
about how to help somebody
when really we need somebody who shows
up with a sandwich on their belt you
know with somebody who can show up with
like
uh like i said i'll give you a ride home
not like somebody's looking at every
individual act as a potential threat
right although i think the sandwich
thing
i would probably be creating a fuss
every day if i knew this
but they were going to send someone with
a sandwich you know what i mean
would i be in the middle of the street
go i know yeah and then i'd be like
you got turkey no not turkey
beef i'll take the corned beef russian
dressing no
call the pastrami cops call the pastrani
cops yes
well but wouldn't that be a great world
if that was the problem i love that idea
conan o'brien is calling the pastrami
cops too often
we have the city's pastrami budget is
going through the roof
we have to figure out we have to defund
the pastrami cops
that's the world i want to live in you
know what i love having you
on the show i love talking to you
because you're that great combination of
uh
funny uh but also i always learn things
from you
and i always feel better off
uh about and i feel a little more
hopeful after we have our conversations
so
and that's a nice feeling that is a
really nice feeling and as always
as i always say we're doomed
you know what always end on your a
material yes exactly you heard it here
we're doomed
new episodes of united shades of america
with w kamau bell
air every sunday at 10 o'clock p.m on
cnn and it's a spectacular show and you
got to check it out if you're not
uh w kamau bell thank you sir i bow to
you
i do this to you okay i'm getting a hug
again someone
also this is from the aclu oh cool well
you don't throw it there you go there
you go
there we go nice sticky yeah oh i was
going to put that in my hair for a
[Laughter]
second